[Music]
in mommy's milk news Mambo's bill have
you tasted it you said you're gonna talk
didn't taste it yet car later no that
would be the first thing I would ask for
I'm curious
that's good to know submitted by Joe
from Canada Canadian Jew name taker you
can tell unique biter a young mom
catches her 58 year old nanny chugging
her bottled breast milk see that's weird
she knows something that you don't know
yeah that's weird cuz I wouldn't want to
drink the titty milk of someone else I
don't know that's like eating a random
person's [ __ ] out whatever it tastes
like really sweet like it's just like
really good milk maybe I just maybe I
cuz I haven't tried it I do it's all
pump right and I see it and I'm like I
don't want to [ __ ] drink this [ __ ]
like if I had titties I would do it it's
not calm its food is between Teddy milk
income this big difference you can't get
nutrients from come come how many tribes
have you seen no know where there's a
baby sucking on the guy's dick and he's
just hanging off his dick in the tribe
you see you see the baby on the video
the visual no cuz I'm kind of show I'm
trying to prove to her because you're
the but there is no kid sucking on the
guy's dick tonight
children kids he even try to suck on man
nipples yep
yeah it's true when I'm burping tech
he's starting to suck on my arm cuz I'm
like just looking for a nipple honey
Isaac don't you but when you hold tight
good have you ever let him lick on your
nipple anything it's too small I tried
like so many times
because you want a bond right I would
try it no fires are for you sick dad
it's for bonding it's tough for like not
for you for the mom and guiding the
bulls are in the wrong place I realized
really in all the ways no cuz you know
girls like the titties here
okay he's usually like the nipples are
kind of in the sense of being bi yeah it
so it's on its bull's eye so when you
wouldn't you hold the baby mmm
I guess soon as they go like this is
perfectly right there garnet bulls it's
towards the bottom so when the baby is
going like this that nipples way way
below um so I'm always trying to like
figure out how to put them there and I
just can't get it to catch that's how
babies bond in the first year
ya know mothers bond with that exist or
parent scientific there's a lot of
things that that feminism say that goes
against science I believe I don't know
[Music]
the kids just having your shirt off but
they don't need to suck on your nipple
bond that's it what are these for yeah
we have useless Nippon you do did I get
blessed with such big areolas and so
much nerve endings if I can't use it
[Laughter]
[ __ ] Cochino very weight so yeah this
mom this 27 year old mom from Taiwan oh
dude what the [ __ ] oh wait no the
nanny's not that okay though the mom is
Tywin the nanny is probably 31 Oh or
Filipino Filipino nannies are really
popular in Asia and I need to do huh so
this mom she she posted this video on
her Facebook page a surveillance video
where you could see the nanny
feeding the baby what differences I
won't be in the videos I have that video
clip but in the video clip you can't see
her actually drinking the milk cuz the
mom said that she's feeding her baby
girl so this mom she has two kids a
two-year-old son and this newborn baby
girl so there's a little bit of milk
left in the bottle and so she you could
see the nanny look up to the security
camera because she was about to open it
and then she ends up not opening it she
leaves the bottle closed she picks up
the baby with the bottle and she goes
into another room and she she lays the
baby down and then she goes into a blind
spot where the campus security camera
can't see her and she just chugs the
rest of the way how does she know that
she checked it then because then right
after the mom said that she - burping
herself is this because it could be what
people don't understand it could be you
know Chinese people always notice we
serve booze okay so it could be the baby
she didn't want the baby to waste the
food so she's like are you gonna finish
this plate I'm gonna finish it for you
yeah you're 100% correct I was thinking
like maybe she believed that it would
make sure you more youthful by dreaming
like breast milk can't you just save it
for because of the expiration date of it
what you never live in a Chinese
household as soon as the grandma opens
the refrigerator and all the things are
about to expire they're gonna make a
meal out of all that [ __ ]
nothing is ever wasted yeah but two
hours is okay no but what if that milks
been there for like a week or a day that
would never happen
what cuz it breast milk doesn't last a
week however long it is what if it's on
its last hour no that [ __ ] is nasty
let's just say that yeah so this is the
second time that she started oh my god
she's just doesn't want to waste milk so
the first time uh it was a similar
situation where she noticed that the
baby finish the milk way too fast oh
[ __ ] like what the hell so then um she
ends up confronting the nanny
and the nanny was like well yeah I did
drink it haha what you cops and she was
just like you know what my own so that
first time it was just like okay there's
a second time yeah cuz it's like you
drink my [ __ ] babe my tit milk
see yeah yeah I'm just gonna give you
one I'm gonna give you a warning okay
exactly
[ __ ] it okay she gave her a warning and
then she said you know what if the baby
girl doesn't finish them they'll give it
to my son like he can finish the milk so
that makes sense yeah so then so that
was the first time and then the second
time with the security footage she is
confessing she's like yeah I did drink
it but you know what my previous
employer let me drink the milk like they
get Idol to the milk she was like yeah
they they would let me take whatever was
left over they let me take it home and
then I guess the nanny was saying that
this the mom is mean and as she was like
being self she flipped it on really
you're not gonna drink it anyway I can't
let this go hey this is good milk
supposed to be one of the perks of the
job
I guess I wouldn't think this [ __ ] is
weird if she was like well there's a lot
of like antibodies like nutritional
stuff a clue I'd be like okay so she's
taking the more scientific okay it's not
as [ __ ] weird but this is [ __ ]
weird she just doesn't want to waste if
it's scientific way that she's entitled
to her milk that's like she warned her
like she's like hey it's not good yeah
dude something like what a sneaky [ __ ]
I want to [ __ ] it KTV I didn't get shoes
you know like that was a nice pattern
that is a nice house that's a really
nice house no the baby she's looking
sneaky [ __ ] dude she looks at the
camera all baby Nikki you know what like
oh I can't wait to drink this [ __ ]
why so goes over here she's acting like
it's a [ __ ] crack rock dude how good
is Katy milk is it that addictive it
must be really good
yeah bar you gotta let us know she's
pretty she's really key looks like she's
young 27 damn she's not Asian genes
cross I know younger boy got a look at
alien I think no there's a little girl
older woman I think it's just the
epicanthal fold that like oh his eyes
the white part I like his cheeks it's a
trip cause like so uh having typing out
like he had like uh like one of his what
is it tear ducts was clogged so he would
get a lot of like mucus and stuff and we
thought he had pinkeye but they're like
we talked to his pediatrician and
they're like no actually that's more
more like newborns like you know they're
just working stuff out of there like
like there's just I'm still working
itself out and then I'm like well how do
I clear that up and then she was oh you
just add a couple drops of breast milk
in his aiya I mean what the [ __ ] yeah
that's my you that I was like I drop
babies yeah and I did it and then like
it cleared up a little bit that's great
yeah mom's to just like lick it off
their eyes like a dog [ __ ] kids
aren't puppy love home my friend's mom
said that my friend's mom said that when
he was a little boy and he had a stuffy
nose she would suck the boogers out of
his nose I think that's natural though
she's Chinese way tree and it's like
animal love you know
you do that with paperclip oh it's not a
better mother's job that's him I'll do
it
Oh like the eye boogers suck out the
buggers are just with your ear to do
chin what do you mean that's my son I
bet pedophile I don't know you see some
[ __ ] I watch you we do do some things
together that if people don't know how
relationship great what would you do
don't say [ __ ] like that that's weird
yeah don't say you watch this hair
responsible dad no you said we do some
[ __ ] people didn't know our relationship
that's weird
oh I turned on music didn't like you he
likes Hawaii he does my music got me I'm
in the room I saw his head I'm not like
any closes that much I'll be like I'll
be like back here like he's with taiga
I'm usually like this you could never
take a break on 100 there's never been a
time when Tycho's not wet sure he's
always wet oh like it's wet hair wet
body is very moist baby just a
well-lubricated it's hard cuz he always
has said the a/c on yeah but I told you
he's my kid so he's probably hot like me
we're both being tortured what he's my
kid too what the [ __ ] obviously he has
my gene if he's sweating like a
[ __ ] I don't know beads of sweat
coming down she puts another blanket on
no IDs greasy better what did you the
grease comes from and sweat [ __ ]
holes was it that the most interesting
you've ever heard in your whole entire
life I don't even know what you guys
just talked about but anyways please
subscribe for more random videos more
funny content and more hahaha poopoo in
your pants stuff go ahead subscribe and
for more videos
right now
[Music]